[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh who's next to come sit on Santa's lap
and tell them their Christmas wishes
hello Santa aren't you I've been
drinking my milk but I'll save you a
glass Santa would you like a Christmas
perhaps a new shiny toy fire truck no I
got something different I need Sean
Payton to stop using taste and he'll so
much he's killing me with drew Brees in
the fantasy playoffs what pay something
else stealing touches and touchdowns
from Brees Mountain chimera I can't even
use taste a melon the Flex what about
this how about a new station every young
person seems to want a new videogame
system right so the system we need fixes
the Niners backfield I love Kyle
Shanahan but he can't stick with one guy
these are very esoteric Christmas wishes
do you have anything more traditional
that you would like yeah I need it
traditionally I don't know good wide
receiver for Carson Wentz in the stretch
run Oh Merry Christmas young man well
it's not quite Christmas just yet Santa
but it is time for your fantasy fire
drill
[Music]
Wow from the sports book at Caesar's
Palace in Fabulous Las Vegas is your
fantasy fire drill and here's your host
[Applause]
hey go back to work you got a game
tomorrow man you can take that to see ya
hey welcome in it's your fantasy fire
July am at camp and this is the fantasy
playoffs you have made it if you're
watching I assume you're in the fantasy
playoffs congratulations if you're
watching for entertainment value we'll
bring a little bit of that as well but
we're gonna get you ready for the
fantasy playoffs if you're on a bye you
want to get ready for next week we'll
have some information there for you you
can join us every well one more week
that's right next week so our last show
11:30 Eastern 8:30 Pacific right here at
the sports book in Las Vegas at Caesars
and of course you could join us on all
bleacher report platforms and I'll be in
the app as soon as this show is over for
30 more minutes taking your questions
will get the plenty of your questions on
the show today YouTube I see you we
always have you covered injuries and
actives coming up in a matter of seconds
we'll also get to sleepers so this week
I'll have my fantasy marketplace out
there for you we got you covered we'll
have a little campfire talk coming up
but we'll get you right into the
injuries here to start things off get a
lot of big names banged up
obviously fantasy playoffs you're trying
to put the best possible lineup out
there and you'll need some of those
sleepers as well Hollywood Brown for the
Ravens today expect it to play we're
gonna get these updated throughout the
show these are all just coming down
right now but he's expected to play wide
receiver 3 to me not the best game for
him Greg Olson is out today so couple
things here force your start in DJ more
we're not worried about that Curtis
Samuel wide receiver 3 if you're in DFS
you want a free play they have the
Falcons Ian Thomas is probably dirt
cheap on there you could take a look at
them if you're really hurting will
fuller today don't have this officially
but he's not expected to be out there
now I have a quandary I have will fuller
I also have Kenny Stills if you're
really stop Kenny Stills is an OK wide
receiver 3 to throw in there willful are
not expected to play but not officially
yet Stafford's out look the the Lions
quarterback situation is not ideal I
want to put this out there
don't keep Stafford around if they lose
today they could shut him down there's
no reason for him to play anymore
the receivers haven't been hurt too much
by all the backups that have played but
Stafford is out I'm just telling you
don't need to keep him around now couple
things here on Minnesota feelin's
doubtful we don't have official word
he's not expected to play there you go
it just comes down
Adam Phelan is out today
not a surprise first of all you can play
Kyle Rudolph with top ten confidence
he's been in that conversation since
Dylan has been hurt hopefully but we
can't ever expect it or assume it deal
in his back next week now you don't see
Dalvin cook sneem on here he did not get
an official injury designation so
they're saying the shoulder is good to
go it's exactly what he said I still
think Alexander Madison who I put my
Friday sleepers article is a decent flex
he's a good player and if they have a
lead maybe they go more Madison to keep
cook healthy maybe on bail we found this
out yesterday is out today so allow
Powell where do I have them I have them
right in in that nice flex range 2930
range I think that's what he is someone
close to the Jets told me literally 10
minutes ago he will be the guy in that
back a little insider information I
don't give you a lot of it I have it
there it's gonna be Bilal Powell more
than ty Montgomery today for the New
York Jets oh he's a good flex play with
some up side against the Miami Dolphins
Ryan Griffin don't have an official word
but he is expected to play and the t
white Hilton is out again today so we'll
talk about somebody who can get as a
sleeper and we have an update here will
fuller is out today so there you go
Kenny Stills but back to the Colts for a
second we'll give you a receiver that's
a sleeper you know I love Jack Doyle
we'll get into more of that still know
Eric Ebron but Marlin Mac is back today
for the Colts a low-end RB 2 you can
forget about Jonathan Williams all right
here's our late game inactives this is
what we know right now some things
artificial Juju's out and James Conner
they're both out today we gave you a
betting Snell I'll stick with betting
Snell as a solid RB to James Washington
a solid wide receiver three and one more
Vance McDonald who's been more down than
up he's got the Cardinals today we know
we love that matchup so Vance McDonald
certainly in the arrow pointing up for
him today Damian Williams is out and
Darryl Williams went on the IR this week
so LeSean McCoy a decent RB to yes does
have the Patriots not the best matchup
and Darwin Thompson I'll say this if you
don't play him today you should at least
pick him up because why well he could be
the number two back down the stretch
here for the Chiefs and they haven't
stuck with one guy all season long
Julian Edelman Sunil are both expected
to be out there you're only playing
Edelman and then Adam Humphreys is going
to be out late
today and I bring that up not because
you're thinking about using Adam
Humphries but because in Friday sleeper
article I did feature AJ Brown because
he's got the Raiders AJ Brown could get
more targets without a multi-cell wonder
Renfro is out that we don't know about
Josh Dickus but he is a true gametime
decision so if you have to make a lineup
decision about Josh Jacobs have you put
them to flex so you can move to somebody
else just in case he doesn't play the
report is it's a broken shoulder blade
very painful to play through if you're
really stuck Jalen rashard not a bad
name to pick up plug and play if Jacobs
can't go and general Everett is out
Tyler Higbee well I don't love them this
week still pretty good matchup against
the Seattle Seahawks now here's Monday
Night Football this markie NFC matchup
gets its own page daniel jose at
everything or both down Eli Manning
coming back the deepest of sleepers why
cuz Ryan Fitzpatrick ripped up Eagles
last week Jordan Howard and Aguilar we
don't know yet I don't expect either
player if they do play to have much of a
role
I love mild Sanders once again I think
he'll win you a fantasy championship and
then for angle art well if he's not in
there Jeffery gets a little bit of a
boost and we know we still go with
Earths and we still think Connor is a
top 10 option now
here's I want to tell you it's a little
campfire talk time you're in the fantasy
playoffs you've gotten this far
congratulations you did it but the
foundation players of your team need to
stay in your lineup stick with your guys
there is a player who want a freakin NFL
MVP last year I'm getting multiple
questions about mr. Patrick mahomes you
can't have Hall & Oates with just one
you can't have a Hall with just enough
you can't do it you can't sing rich girl
with just hall you can't get to your
fantasy playoffs without that guy and
your lineup and I get it he's got the
Patriots I totally understand but then
you're ignoring the fact
that Lamar Jackson had a great game
against the Patriots deshaun Watson just
had a great game against the New England
Patriots tough matchups go both ways so
the Patriots yes or a tough defense
but Patrick mahomes is a tough matchup
for the New England Patriots unless
there's a big injury out there don't get
cute when it comes to your guys you're
sticking with patch with the Holmes he
got you this far now let's get some
questions in here we'll get the plenty
of them on the show today week 14 maybe
beyond for some of you would I be wrong
for starting the green baby if it's a
kicker this week Gregg no you would not
Green Bay my number one defense for week
number 14 fire them up with confidence
Hut Penny Madison moster all the Niners
backfield we'll get to that I got to go
Kareem hug today in that spot there for
Irish next question Brady or 10 Hill I
have Tannehill a couple spots higher
sounds like Ryan Seminoles gonna be the
future and current quarterback of the
Tennessee Titans darn old may feel there
Fitzpatrick Ryan Fitzpatrick is ballin
right now Dave Runyon EMT on the
jump-off couple weeks ago I'll stick
with him today against the New York Jets
a revenge game we love those Griffin
orga sickie assuming Griffin's good to
go I think I just stick with him I do
like both these tight ends you're sick
he has been playing well for a couple
weeks down the cooker Benny Snell that
look cook you didn't seem on the injury
report you're playing down the cook
stick with your guys today now we take
you to the sports book because people on
the west coast got up early because they
need help because the fantasy playoffs
matter then we bring them in right now
gentlemen your names Brian Brian Mike
all right where you from by the way
Atlanta Georgia Atlanta New York New
York all right New York out my way
what's your question
Green Bay or Minnesota got those two
defense that's with defense quasi Pat's
Green Bay is number one this week I love
the matchup for them and I think they
take you to the next round sound good
good all right thank you got it there
you go we got more to come right now in
fact we have your week 14 sleepers
[Music]
let me tell you something if you make
the playoffs if you're an MLM we'll be
baseball team they change their lineup
up right they don't necessarily have the
same eight guys in there you may be seen
thinking the same way you've gotten this
far congratulations but you're still
tinkering with that lineup yeah you're
sticking with the guys at the top you're
playing your Dowling cokes or Patrick
mahomes your album and Camaros no doubt
about it but if you've been streaming
quarterbacks all season long
don't stop now and don't stop this week
when you can play that's right Ryan
Fitzpatrick is gonna win you a fantasy
championship I have done this in the
past with Derek Anderson and Matt Moore
and Jeff Garcia I'm going way back there
you can win a championship streaming
quarterbacks this guy's got the Jets
he's got the Giants he's got the bangles
coming up you might stick with Ryan
Fitzpatrick for a full month of December
and he'll get you a ring it's the only
ring he's gonna win this year but he's
got a good matchup he's thrown the ball
somehow dafonte Parker's great now his
sick he's getting the job done they
really don't have a running game Ryan
Fitzpatrick is gonna be on some
championship rosters now the tight end
position we know very tough to deal with
if you're reaching a little deep it's no
offense I can't say I'm super pumped
about this but right now if you're
scrambling this morning you're looking
for tight end help drew LOX the guy
they're an evaluation mode fan all of it
Courtland Sutton is the only name might
even consider all the receivers for the
Denver Broncos
there have been flashes we've seen some
big plays I'll give you a little heads
up on 2020 I'm gonna have this guy and a
lot of my best fall teams I think it's
gonna break out seasons coming but what
if he does it today the matchup is not
bad at all take a look at Noah fan maybe
and cheap play for DFS lineup now one
more here and I hinted at this one
earlier the Colts do not have tu I
Hilton Eric Ebron is on the IR and Zach
Pascal who burned us a couple weeks ago
I'm well aware of that did come through
last week I think he can come back this
week
no Hilton chicoy Brissette oh by the way
they get the Buccaneers yeah I'm gonna
wipe away last week with the Jaguars
as I'm gonna take more of your questions
all right let's go week 14 questions
we're jumping into them right now I
think there are miles miles Sanders
table quarter mixing for rb2 I think I'm
gonna go a mile Sanders here I think
he's the most important player to the
Philadelphia Eagles right now in terms
of success outside of Horowitz next
question up here should I start quoting
Sutton and Stefon Diggs sit Alshon
Jeffrey I think I'm ok with that one
game in two months
Hunter Henry your mark Enders Andrews's
was safer play closer Henry's are upside
play if you think you're a big underdog
you go with Hunter Henry
next up here using one running back as a
flex it one for net chopper Jones I like
all of these guys
I'm gonna sit Aaron Jones only because
you've been a little next up here who
can support work power Montgomery I told
you I got a little birdie in my ear
close to the jet saying it's gonna be
Powell and I fully expect law Powell to
be the guy for the Jets today start one
guys Freeman or tomorrow Williams I'm
gonna go with Freeman I love the matchup
against Carolina look with diced and
with Adrian Peterson did it to the
Panthers last week alright we go to the
wall for a viewer question now that mr.
mania is back in Jacksonville do you
think that offense is going to blow up
and explode and turn into something fun
blow up we appreciate the question there
because it's not like they blew up with
foals foals was throwing a lot of passes
last week they laid the biggest at it I
get the worst possible time in a great
matchup I'm kind of glossing over that
Minshew versus foals I don't see a big
change in the offense DJ shark was
posting numbers with foals and with
Minshew Leonard fournette like I said
it's on its way to a low-key 90 catch
season I don't see anything changing
there but the answer the question I do
not see the offense blowing up either so
the jaguars are pretty much status quo
regardless of who is playing quarterback
for the team we appreciate the question
we'll get some more your questions
coming up in a little bit a ring at the
door who could it be my craft you know
get some good old hands-on advice you
know like Robert I'm looking for a good
hot tip or else
make you feel like a morning DJ
interviewing Jerry Jones sound cell
watch out honors kid this is time right
now it's the marketplace to fantasy it's
your stock exchange no now you're happy
I'm back now I'm your guy always happy
to see you Andy you're our guy yeah I'm
your guy I'm your guy you started it
rookie Phil last few weeks how'd that
work out for you I mean Andy that was
the strategy right we keep you fresh for
the playoffs you're with ten I came in
last week and I watch the Jets exactly
our strategy work to keep you fresh and
then when you win our LA counts what are
you guys even talking what do we get
back into that oh it's really a shamone
welcome back nd uh let's roll out the
red carpet for red hair and Andy what's
that supposed to do do you guys look
good up some throw the ball here I throw
the ball there real easy to say from
that side of the table listen you wanna
throw the ball here we want you to throw
the ball here
you don't need to throw in here okay
it's about throwing in here you throw it
here your Andy Dalton this is your sweet
spot I mean nobody throws a 4-yard out
like you what are you kidding me
that's what you're that's what you're
coming with here that's what you're
telling me come on you want to know how
much we love you Joe and Charlie check
down Charlie Charlie as you're
evaluating your team's here look the
guys you're gonna stick with you know
that already but what you might be
looking at as those fringe players ones
that you always make a decision on when
it comes to setting your lineup each
week so let's help you out who's up and
who's down for the fantasy playoffs and
we'll start with a quarterback who I do
like Carson Wentz play great last week I
don't care that the Eagles lost I don't
you know why cuz they're still in
contention that is a nice tiebreaker
when you're stuck who is still in
contention the Philadelphia 'ls the
record looks awful but the Cowboys are
bad too they're still in contention he's
got a great schedule the Redskins he's
got two matchups with the Giants in
there he still plays the Cowboys the
schedules good he's playing good enough
football they'll be throwing a bunch cuz
their defense isn't very good
Carson Wentz can still win you a fantasy
championship this season maybe not the
way you expected it now we're gonna go
from a contending team somehow so a
Super Bowl contender and the Niners are
going wait a minute why would they be
down why are they down they're down
because they have all of these guys Matt
Brito didn't seem on the injured part
he's back today now where he most art
was the guy last week my guy Tevin
Coleman has been a ghost for a month now
oh by the way Jeff Wilson randomly
scores I love Kyle Shanahan he's great
for fantasy except when he's using all
of these running backs who can you
confidently say you could put in your
lineup right now as the guy in the
Niners backfields nobody it should be
most it could be Breda heck it could be
Tevin Coleman in a couple weeks there's
just not enough reliability in one
player
in this backfield now there is one
player who was emerging on a team that
is fully an evaluation mode and that is
Darius guys Darius guys last week was RB
one I got to talk to him last week on
another program and I said dude you were
running back one he said that's awesome
Darius Geiss is now the man for the
Redskins yeah they have Adrian Peterson
but they don't have much else there I
think he's gonna get plenty of carries
down the stretch and oh by the way a
great matchup today against the Green
Bay Packers now we go to the other side
here schedule scare me
josh allen has been a pretty good
fantasy quarterback has he been top 5 no
and that's why he's in this conversation
he's typically in that 7 to 12 range
well what does he have
he's got the Ravens he's got the
Steelers he's got the Patriots that's
what we're looking at here for the
fantasy playoff matchups they're in
contention I'm not saying he's gonna be
bad I'm not saying you have to bench him
but I think those matchups scare me off
just enough to say you lower
expectations and maybe if you think yes
somebody like a Carson Lynch with a far
better matchup
you might bench Allen one of these weeks
not totally down but lower expectations
for Allen in the fantasy playoffs now
one more here we're gonna give you lots
gonna be tight end I told you about him
last week no Eric Ebron Hilton remains
out Jack Doyle was a monster last week
plenty of volume he's a really good
tight end unfortunately they're icky
bran there sometimes targets are stolen
Ebron gun Jack Doyle lit it up last week
and Jack Doyle can keep it up today
against Tampa Bay Buccaneers Jack Doyle
is gonna be a target monster he's got a
shot to be a top five tight end for the
rest of the season that's your fantasy
marketplace but now more of your
questions and hello YouTube we are here
for you specifically how can I help you
in week forty mile Sanders or Crowder
Tony you got to go mile Sanders I'm
telling it's gonna win you a
championship this year next up deshaun
Watson or Russell Wilson oh my goodness
who's got this question
I'm gonna go deshaun Watson by that much
it's very close for this week next Baker
Mayfield is a sleeper but a Rogers has
been on fire did I choose one or the
other you got to go with Rogers if you
have a sleeper that's fine but not when
you have a great quarterback Aaron
Rodgers putting your line of Carson
Wentz or Tasha Allen I think Carson
Wentz can be top five this week I'm
gonna play them against the Giants
on Monday Night Football flop our Joe
Mixon fair but I'm gonna go Joe Mixon I
think there's more guarantee touches for
him today with the Bengals Robbie
Anderson Zach Pascal or Cole Beasley I'm
gonna put my money where my mouth is to
tell you to play
Zach Pascal great matchup against Tampa
Bay Buccaneers so the wall for a
celebrity question I'm Matt how you
doing this is your colleague from WWE
Tom Phillips I have a question for you
as an Eagles fan myself I'm curious
about this and fantasy Carson Wentz
how much do you trust him down the
stretch considering how the Eagles will
play lately his struggles with his wide
receiver core and a follow-up question
if you had to choose between hurts and
God er who's your pick got or it's been
kinda on the uptick lately hurts has his
good days obviously can have nine
catches or more but sometimes it's hit
or miss here down the stretch with these
NFC East teams so what do you think
thanks to my buddy Tom fells for the
question he's an Eagles fan playing
fantasy here rooting here admitting the
Eagles are not necessarily the best spot
just talked about Carson Wentz a lot
look I don't care about the Eagles
record or what they're doing he
performed well last week and the
schedule is good down the stretch I
don't care if the Eagles make the
playoffs I want Carson Wentz to play
well and I think you take advantage of
those matchups
I would also say it's over got it
although both once again or in my top
ten for this week thanks to Tom for the
question more your questions coming up
but now we revisit the inactives for
this week what do we know now Marquis
Brown is in today not a surprise so we
will call him a wide receiver 3 Olson is
out as I talked about you roll with your
normal guys DJ more Curtis Samuel
Christian McCaffrey Ian Thomas is a
basically a free space on your DFS car
today will fuller is out if you're
hurting you're reaching real deep I am
doing so Kenny Stills is worth a look
Matthew Stafford just noting that he's
out again we've seen a million different
guys now play quarterback for Detroit
hasn't hurt the team too much but you
don't need to keep Stafford on your
roster that's a dead space on your bench
Adam Thielen is gonna be out again today
now two things here Kyle Rudolph can
remains in my top 10 he's been great
since Trudeau uh dealin's been out and
also you don't see Dalvin cook same here
did not get an injury designation role
with him with confidence Alexander
Madison is a deep reach a flex play if
you need him leave
Bell is out today so I will tell you
that you can call Bilal Powell a solid
flex option and as I said earlier I was
told he will be the guy not ty
Montgomery and Ryan Griffin is in he
remains a top 10 option CY Hilton is out
we like Zach Pascal we love Jack Doyle
and Marlon Mac is back this week a
decent not great but a decent RB two
Buccaneers run defense is pretty solid
here's your late-game inactives that we
know right now the injuries Juju's down
James Connors down
Benny Snell is solid not spectacular
same thing for James Washington Damian
Williams is down Darryl Williams on the
ir McCoy a solid RB two against the
Patriots and if you reach a real deep
Darwyn Thompson at least pick him up
he's out there Edelman and Sinuhe we
don't know about officially but both are
expected to play obviously only goal
with Edelman
Humphries is down means I love AJ Brown
against the Raiders Renfro down but most
importantly we can't tell you for sure
that Josh Jacobs is gonna play a true
gametime decision so don't assume he's
gonna be out there put em in your Flex
give yourself a chance to pivot and
gentle ever it is down so Tyler Higbee
is still in play for the tight end
position and quickly on Monday Night
Football we know already that it's gonna
be Eli in for Daniel Jones Steve Sleeper
Ingram is out Golden Tate back so you're
good with him Howard and Aguilar we're
not really sure about you love Myles
Sanders and you feel better about
Jeffrey if we do not have Aguilar out
there now it's time for your speed round
[Music]
I think we saved the quickest speed
round for week 14 code we gotta go baby
little women Christmas here's a headband
I got a new whistle also for I know
shoes back we're gonna go with DJ car
next up here James wider Calvin Ridley
likes the same play relieves or up side
play against the Panthers today you know
what your matchup looks like hide and so
nice Nell or penny
we're gonna go snail and penny how's
that oh it's a mix play went or Winston
I think when she's got top 5 potential
is today I'm gonna play whens for you
next up gets icky McDonald or Goddard I
got a government Vance's your up site
place got the Cardinals coach I'd start
you against the card let's do it and
let's also get some challah notes music
on down let's really go there it is Hall
and Oates is here for your fantasy
questions what do I do it lock it
starter sit up you didn't see him on the
injury report you're starting Lockett
today forget last week some guys have
bad games of phantoms Josh Jacobs Hobart
airlock it might flex I'm not messing
around I'll play Tyler Lockett I'll tell
you to do that right now everybody do
that right now
st. Stephen's against the Niners in the
Worland sore Carolina against Atlanta
I'm gonna go with the Saints defense
against the Niners cuz it's in two
worlds baby Jimmy's in trouble today
Rodgers wins Thunder mahomes this is the
only time I'm gonna tell you to sit down
mahomes who's got both these quarterback
Aaron Rodgers your guy Madison down the
cook your gullet cook he's not an injury
report we're good to go
that's your show but thirty minutes I'm
going to jump into the app and take your
question and we're back Nick these crazy
people and me for one more show 8:30
Pacific 11:30 Eastern
I'm dancing and you'll be the answer
when you win this week i'm matt camp
this is been your fantasy fire drill
I've heard animal
[Music]
you
you